[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
we're not playing along this what the
[ __ ] dude submarine
okay so yeah this is just a brawl i
think yeah no
no no team in the water but if anyone
wants to team with me
but no teams all right oh free for all
yeah
yeah otter gang karate rhino
where's the gray cat joe scratching my
ass hold on
oh you can pick different colors what
yeah
oh
guys i'm a golden cat that's beautiful
i'm a white pink dog how do we not know
about this sooner
well it's convenient when you're playing
in teams because everyone can look
different
oh yeah oh you're like the the japanese
kitty with the hand that goes down
yeah money cat okay i think that's the
japanese word yeah
[ __ ] out of each other [ __ ] yeah come
here come here come here come here
come here
no no no no no no no
no
what the [ __ ] there's a rocket a [ __ ]
otter that can't swim
are you serious leave me alone oh
peter's got the attacker
oh joel's got the best weapon oh jesus
everyone dave
submersible boys how do you climb hold
is click and hold space
oh yeah yeah and it just climbs
automatically yeah
what is happening get up there joel i
try to control
hello
[Laughter]
joel is still alive somewhere oh there
you go there he goes
good job the captain yeah maybe you can
get on the table oh no never mind
yeah but i don't know how to do it
captain
yeah captain all right wait
don't hit me i need to figure out how to
[ __ ] yeah don't hit you like you
didn't hit me at the start sure
oh man oh look at it
oh i see it so that's give me this give
me this
oh nice oh give him payback dave
don't do it what is that rocket what the
[ __ ] was that
[ __ ] [ __ ] say jack
goddammit that's not me oh there's a
rocket
again that's what got me last time
he's got it he's got oh my god he just
got it he's got it he knows what he's
doing
i can climb yeah all right okay okay all
right
it's the card swiping over again
there you go oh i see you guys are going
i think dave's just gonna win by default
do you hold down with both both mouse
buttons uh just the mouse the
main mouse button and oh there's a bomb
i'm using controller
i don't know how to play oh dave what
happened joel
oh my god
what an amazing punch so it's first to
three
i think suicide pact
can everyone stop putting me no
it doesn't work corpse the golden rule
remember
kill pewdiepie please that was messed up
you killed me
get up yeah the golden rule
hey remember the golden rule corbs
remember the golden rule
oh no dave no no remember the golden
claim dave remember the goal why does
that happen
stop
no that's not what i want you to do who
climbs oh my god it doesn't climb
dave yeah mine doesn't claim either i
don't know how to do it
[Laughter]
i'm so strong i love you holding the
submarine together
sean you're just standing there yeah i'm
holding the submarine together
i'm not going anywhere i'll go down with
this ship
in half dave get him i i've got a plan
that's kind of the plot oh wait yeah
let's hold on and see who wins
all right this titanic isn't going
anywhere we keep it together this time
boys
i feel like i should be closer to you
dave yeah hold hands
yes hey this is not right
sean is the captain now i didn't know if
it would go under i didn't want people
to wait too long
nice sorry dave there could be only one
jack
on the titanic nice
come get up oh not the bomb no
stop him i'm running no i'm guessing oh
god where the [ __ ] is that
all right get me get i want the cat food
i want the cat food
oh the spinach oh is that oh no you're
going just
going inside
how does the rocket keep hitting me i
don't understand hey let me
let me just get i just want hey let me
talk to you real quick all right all
right what do you want to talk about
what's up oh dave's back godzilla
what'd you say about my dad i'm coming
up there oh
[ __ ] somersault [ __ ] what's up what's
up
oh corpse why why is david get easy
watch where you're swinging those
mittens corps
i think i'm getting ping that nobody
else has
how does that kill you i have dropped
kicking vengeance now
no no no no god no
leave me alone oh thank god
like go away from me everybody's there
call me i'm crazy
oh
he must be finished oh i actually died
you just beat the kid out of me
this mode's way better all right round
five it keeps going
be careful of corpse you never just
don't want to be the first one to die
every [ __ ] time
[Laughter]
why does he suck at climbing so much
what am i doing wrong
absolutely others can't climb there
but they can swim holy [ __ ]
what is he doing with nunchucks
hold grab and climb nothing else you can
knock yourself out with the nunchucks i
just left
maybe you can't climb right away in real
life yeah you can
okay i got it i got it i got it kill him
[ __ ] him up
[Laughter]
yeah hold me no corpse stop that stop
that right now
you guys are so cute this is
we're all just passed out
no no no no no no no no no no i'm not
dying oh now what a great day help me
come here
you're so late oh my god i'm alive i'm
just chilling i'll never die i will
never let go wow
it's gonna be underwater now oh damn
cats hate water never let go
ah come on fellas what do you mean come
on come on fellas let's wrap it up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm stuck with
my head my head is stuck
what happened
shut up thank
why did you do that it kills you why did
you do that
i didn't do anything i'm an honor you
put me up
i can rock it he just heated it it did
nothing he did just need one more win
oh damn that's a good puppy come on pick
him up
no don't do that that's a bad idea oh
damn he's
very strong look at you go for weapons
real men fight with their fists
come back or their paws or mittens or
whatever you have
oh pull them out throw them out through
that throw up don't do it
wwe check off my submarine
no give me oh it's holding wrong
oh my god
give me something it's not grabbing
anything
you grabbed the tennis racket how's it
going come on
oh come on nice clean i am the victor
the golden kitty oh i could almost grab
the other thing
damn damn gg i like that mode that was
fun
ichiban i don't know i don't know this
might be there but
tips don't die i've never played this
one okay who's going to help me i want
to be an absolute unit this time
you [ __ ] one shot at me every time
that was the rocket
not me uh yeah yeah we were just next to
it every time
yeah the honor sucks don't pick the
otter trust me guys
look at this okay whoa
i'm gonna be a [ __ ] steel rhino uh
all right
kill each other i guess oh god oh god oh
cool
yeah let's go oh
okay you sneaky well i can't jump down
here apparently
oh oh what are you doing with that huh
what you doing with that
stay away from that no i find the
weapons quite difficult to use
yeah but they're super overpowered once
you hit it's crazy yeah you get a hit
you basically win
you win
oh [ __ ] i'm dead i got gay you're right
next to me hello
hello hey hey what's going on dave did
you even did i hit you yeah apparently
i didn't hear anything my fat rolled out
the way nice
are you climbing
i don't think
can we kill him somehow when he's up
there shoot him good luck good luck
i want to see that come true jump okay
oh yeah all the way up god damn
does the gas rise in this or something i
don't think so
uh maybe i mean we died right away
though
here comes the gas
wait the gas the other gas the green
knot
you actually have to climb oh we're dead
oh it smells bad
that's very anticlimactic compared to
falling into the ocean yeah
but it's kind of dark and weird
today i didn't want to make any jokes
about it it's just like okay okay are we
going again
oh [ __ ] that didn't work das boy my
shovel
stop
getting out of here
you're going in the gas boy you're going
in the gas
very stinky gas don't don't do it
don't do it you're all you all have
weapons fight each other
yeah okay get it
get his weapon no don't hurt me
i'm so pathetic
freaking sounds i'm just gonna hold this
racket incorrectly
i just wanna live with the racket please
joel is still alive get joel
please but i'm dead he's dead he's not
dead he's not dead
he's cheating we gotta climb you gotta
come yeah you wanna get climbing boys
it is something funny we're like no no
my ankles
well we see about that
that's what you get
you're shooting there dave thanks
see anyone yet shut up no i jumped into
the gas you're going down boy
oh god damn
[Laughter]
he just got some [ __ ] moves play
tennis
oh no yeah he played the tennis skill
come into play
wait have you actually played titus
felix dude i
district champion 1989.
[Laughter]
why do you guys never [ __ ] die don't
fear the poison
no fear no fear fear i got a good
fear i fear there you go
don't breathe just don't breathe just
don't breathe i think you're in trouble
just jump right yeah let's go
i'm gonna get at least one of those epic
flying kicks from the top in this game
that would be really cool actually oh
wait you pick up these
stop stop hurting me
get up
[Laughter]
join me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] he elbowed you in the face
you're holding it wrong
oh my [ __ ] god it's so frustrating
it's like when you're
fighting game and someone just just a
draw low kick or something
you're just swinging a shovel around all
the time what are you talking about ah
shut up oh no
how did i die
so i had the determination that nobody
didn't have the oxygen i guess
no weapon oh hell yeah oh no
why am i dead all the time come on no no
oh [ __ ] i almost got you
you've angered the kick i knocked myself
out but walking into you
oh no you've known jokes are so stupid
oh mid-air whoa
oh yeah you guys want to go i'm going to
pull this wall
or pull the ball off the wall [ __ ]
that's me
now all right that backfired
oh this is so stupid yeah i heard it
moving target isn't it
yeah oh no oh
oh oh oh get the nunchuck thing
he hasn't he has nothing to do with her
fists he's coming back
i'm holding an arrow can you even do
that
doesn't make any sense oh my god oh my
god
corporal he's not the lion king died
already
the matter are you killed you [ __ ]
virgins and your weapons
oh you boys better be climbing soon
[Laughter]
oh joel got it no he died
wow wow i think you were i think you
were low health and the gas guy
oh that makes sense that makes sense i
think that's what happened to me at
least
oh all right no like that how do you
know just pick him up
no i do not die like that calculated
oh my god are you dead
didn't work oh that wasn't pathetic
i don't want that are you [ __ ]
throwing bricks at me oh [ __ ] there's
bricks i didn't even see that
yeah i could die i could die everybody
could die
die
you think you got the deepest voice
sexiest voice around i'll get you
yeah think just cause your voice is much
hotter than mine
[Laughter]
accent smash your [ __ ] are you dead
dave what's happening oh
i'm very dead okay
immediately oh no climb troll climb get
him
chasing him oh no oh my god
how do you even
oh no you may have the nunchucks but
i've trained in the lollipop blade
oh jesus jesus oh my gosh lagging so bad
oh no oh he's gonna win it
the gas is coming the gas is coming baby
he's gonna win
come here come here i think you're gonna
die sooner there because the gas is
stronger corpse i'm not sure
oh yeah
that's kind of cool you can't just
cheese it early
ah no okay nice all right it's close to
life between course and toss boy
okay yes that's what i wanted to do
yeah my guy just starts running in one
direction too many nunchucks recently
oh wait no of course
no there's no way you're still alive
[Music]
are you dead i hate myself
get him pj get him pj yeah
get him pj you're not holding get him pj
get a pg
that lollipop is the most terrifying
thing in the game
no corpses every time i kill him he just
gets back up
stop no i'm just trying to grab
a weapon you know ah the back of my head
no
how do i get up am i dead no
how do you know all right it turns black
and white
okay dj's got sure as well now this is
really close
damn hey i hate it corpse we gotta we
got to combine
how do you want to combine we got to
kill pj what no no no no
you run around i just got lucky a couple
of times i'm completely down for that
okay
double the power uh pda yeah let's go
all right let's go botanical boys
oh that didn't work at all
don't do anything you regret it yeah
come on joel so it's up to you now oh
sorry i tried to hit
jack
mission accomplished
oh oh you ducked it that was sweet
why did you hit me i don't i don't know
oh no
corpse there's hello enough space for
but
there's no there's no space chords
there's no space
[ __ ] you up no i died are you serious
what yeah that's what i thought they
could think gas like moves over here but
it didn't look like it was let's get him
what the [ __ ]
it's like fortnite guys what the [ __ ] it
looked like i was okay
oh oh oh oh oh oh no i'm lagging oh no
i'm lagging
[Applause]
all right that was fun yeah yeah yeah
that was a lot of fun
so good thanks for having us yeah happy
to be a gamer
hell yeah dude
[Music]
all right well thanks for watching if
you want to become a member it all goes
to charity
check out the game it's in the free demo
right now it's called party animals
the devs are nine 19 year olds which is
epic so
that's it breakfast here
[Music]